more and more Americans are taking a
page from the rest of the world and
turning the cycling for basic
transportation and increasingly that
means electric bikes which help to make
the trip a little easier and a lot less
sweaty one of the best design bikes
we've seen at Wired is the Faraday
porteur
which meld retro classic style with
enough power to turn your daily ride
into a joy ride the batteries are packed
into the downtube it's a it's a nice
design touch that keeps the clean lines
intact and the motor only kicks in when
you pedal you can select from two
different levels of pump depending on
the size of the hill and the size of the
motivation but the Faraday wasn't built
for racing it was built for coffee runs
so it comes with commuter friendly
bamboo fenders front and rear lighting
and an optional front comes in three
basic sizes which fit most people and
the battery powers about 20 miles of
riding it's not cheap though Faraday
cost $3500 so you're not gonna want to
leave it locked up just anywhere that
means you're gonna have to bring all 39
pounds of it inside which is nice if you
have an elevator not so much if you have
stairs where ebikes really shine or on
hills and in a city like San Francisco
the Faraday is 250 watt motorized front
wheel levels out the effort and makes
for some serious fun
you